houses have appreciated 15 in three
months 50
year over year in some market are we in
a bubble
so i think that there's a difference
between a bubble versus
uh fundamental supply and demand so what
happened in 2000
well what happened in 2009 was the
government did a mass amount of
foreclosures and flooded the supply when
demand was staying constant
increased supply demand stays constant
means prices are going to drop right
right today we actually quite the
opposite and what's actually so
interesting jason is you know i've
raised
several four rounds of capital at this
point
every investor when i was raising every
venture capitalist
asked me they said what happens if home
prices decline
right what what is divvy going to do not
one venture capitalists ask me what do
you do when home prices skyrocket
and inventory becomes tighter and so
that's just a lesson in the unknown
unknowns which is
you know just you how the venture mine
thinks right
there's something they're like i have a
chance to ask the founder a question i
should ask them
about what happens if the titanic hits
an iceberg exactly
it's actually not as much about and i
know you spent some time in venture
it's not as much about they actually
care about the answer to that question
as they care about how thoughtful you
are in answering it
yes yes and i understand that i think
the answer for you would be
well if you're raising the price three
percent and the homes gone down 20
in value now the person's underwater and
they're demotivated
but you can always correct that right
well in those situations when we're
sitting on a cash flow stream so we make
enough profit that we can sustain some
hit
yeah in price so we can basically
sustain call it a 15
hit in prices and still break even on
the property and we're fine
um and then in that case where the
customers underwater we'd extend their
lease we'd let them stay in the house
longer build more equity
and then buy back the house when the
time is right these are not
20 million these are not 20 30 million
dollar houses that people overpaid
five or ten million dollars for that
would be a whole different ball game
these are houses people need in a
housing shortage
so are we in a you don't believe we're
in a bubble
so let's let's unpack why we're not in a
bubble in your mind
yes so what we're seeing today is that
uh covid caused this very interesting
market change right where all of a
sudden
no one wanted to sell their homes
because no one wanted to move during a
global pandemic
so supply you can say it stayed constant
to slightly decrease or just less
existing home sales
so you have a case in which supply is
not growing
and at the same time demand start to
spike why did demand spike well because
everyone was living in their studio
apartment was
you know like hey you know would be
great if i bought a single family home
that had a backyard right and some place
for me to actually spend some time
outside so what we did was we actually
saw
um demand go up now this was even more
impacted by the fact
that people who would have typically
sold actually had the opportunity to
refinance
right they refinanced their mortgages
because rates were really low which kept
them in their houses even longer so
supply was even impacted more
so you have demand going up supply going
down and the result of this is that home
prices have started to rise
right and that is a lack of inventory
now how does that
correct itself in the market one you can
add more supply
i don't know how many folks you know
realize but like it takes like five plus
years to build a home
right it just doesn't go up overnight
why because the government puts in
titling and you have to make sure that
the issues in some places those
yes but that's for affordable housing
but yes yes yes but
point being that it just takes a long
time for new build homes right and so
you're not going to flood the market
with supply suddenly
and given the way that work is moving to
be more remote
i actually think that demand is going to
only continue to sustain
so given that i actually think that home
prices are going
to continue to increase and i think that
we've entered just a fundamentally
different time where remote work is
going to be more acceptable
um and that we we're just under supplied
on single-family homes which by
the way was an issue even before coveted
but was exacerbated by covet
is there an issue right now where people
are moving into a kind of yolo moment
and they look at the house they're in
and they're going and buying a second
house somewhere because they don't have
to go to an office
and i'm talking about a slightly higher
end of the market but
i think it's now becoming a trend where
people are like you know i left
brooklyn and i now have a place in
florida or nashville
but i decided to not sell my place in
brooklyn or i was in san francisco
or palo alto i'm going to keep my place
there but i moved to
you know park city because i want to ski
and i can so are there a lot of people
now where they're owning more than one
home and not selling the original one
because let's face it if this is a
better asset
than the stock market is which i think a
lot of people feel this might be a
better asset than the stock market which
feels bubbly
now that's going to constrain supply
even more
is that a trend or is that just
anecdotes that i'm seeing near me
because i hang out with a certain group
of people
uh you definitely hang out with a
certain group of people i definitely
don't know that as
that area the second home market as well
because transparently our customers are
struggling to buy their first home
um i think that if anything jason that's
more factor of
lower interest rates right if you could
refinance out your brooklyn apartment at
two and a half percent
why sell it right i mean that's right
pretty cheap
right to be able to keep it now if
interest rates increase you have a 5-1
adjustable rate mortgage um interest
rates increase in five years maybe
that's something then that you would
consider selling because if you were
paying
six percent on that on that mortgage
even five percent on that mortgage right
all of a sudden maybe you wouldn't be
keeping it as easily
right because you wouldn't be able to
rent it for as much as you're carrying
costs now you're screwed
okay now you have uh folks like
blackrock buying up thousands of homes
reportedly um and sitting on them maybe
or renting i'm not sure what they're
actually doing that's always existed but
it seems to be increasing there was this
big wall street journal article about
that
is that reality um is that causing
problems and if so in which parts of the
market
yeah so we're seeing we call this like
institutional investors
uh we're seeing institutional buyers uh
increase the pace at which they're
buying assets why because there's no
yield you're not getting returns across
the market and so they're turning to
actually
homes which are one appreciating
extremely fast um but then two you can
rent them out and still make a pretty
good return
versus what you can get on maybe a bond
or some other asset class that you would
put your money into
so we are seeing a massive influx of
institutional capital into the single
family rental
market now on the positive side i think
that
for our customers what's nice about that
is when divi goes to bid on a home
we're bidding on behalf of them so we'll
say hey jason we think we should bid
350 000 for this house and you might say
hey dina i actually know the market
it's really hot i think you guys are
bidding too low maybe should 355 or
maybe you'll say hey you guys are
bidding too high let's go to 345. now we
have a range that we we allow
but within that range we have a
conversation we decide on the bidding
strategy and we will go out and bid for
you
uh you are going to get an all cash
offer that's going to have
generally anywhere from zero to five day
due diligence period
will close within two weeks for you and
you just became as competitive
as blackstone when blackstone goes to
bid right so what we do is we take the
average consumer and we make it so that
they can actually compete
with the the blackrock's blackstone's
imitation homes of the world
because we offer as competitive of an
offer that they couldn't do even if they
had a conventional mortgage
today many small business owners are
busier than ever
since they're focused on managing and
growing their business they can't always
spend the time they wish they could on
recruiting and you're only as good as
your team i talk about that all the time
on this podcast
and that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier to find and hire the best
candidates for free
get started by posting your job for free
to reach linkedin's network of 740
million professionals oh my god there's
a lot of people on linkedin fill out
targeted screening questions to get your
role
in front of the most qualified
candidates with the experience skills
and motivation
you need then it's easy to filter and
prioritize the top candidates you'd like
to interview
we love linkedin jobs at launch and at
inside we've hired a second producer
a curriculum designer and a few more
researchers
we are crushing it we're now 18 people
here i can't believe it it used to be me
and like three people
every week nearly 40 million job seekers
visit linkedin
if you've got a job you're gonna find
those job seekers on linkedin
and they're gonna find that right person
for your role right now
don't waste time post your first job for
free that's right free linkedin is so
supportive of this podcast
that they're gonna let you post your
first job for free to prove to you
how amazing their product is that's how
confident they are linkedin.com
unicorn that's linkedin.com unicorn to
post your first job listing for free
of course terms and conditions do apply
because they giving you that free job
posting